die pariser kathedrale notre dame in
flammen bilder die die welt im april
2009 10 sehr bewegt
die filmemacher claude ruey und tectura
ag hatten nur wenige wochen vor dem
brand eine dokumentation über die
weltberühmte kirche gedreht
nach dem brand war uns klar dass unsere
aufnahmen jetzt einen besonders großen
wert haben wir haben einen moment in der
geschichte von notre dame eingefangen
den wir der öffentlichkeit zurück geben
können ob europäer amerikaner asiate
oder paris jeder hat eine erinnerung an
notre dame aus ihrem film material vor
dem brand und den neuen aufzeichnungen
nach der zerstörung produzierten sie
eine zweite dokumentation rebuilding
notre dame
diese begleitet den wiederaufbau der
berühmten kirche die aufnahmen der
filmemacher sind die einzigen ihrer art
aus dem inneren der kathedrale
[Musik]
diese aufnahmen sind in der tat
besonders weil sie in virtueller
realität gefilmt sind sprich um 360 grad
in sehr hoher auflösung und 3d dadurch
entsteht ein bild für das linke und
eines für das rechte auge
man hat das gefühl wirklich vor ort zu
sein
mit hilfe einer virtual reality brille
kann man in den 16 minütigen film
komplett eintauchen
sensoren sorgen dafür dass man das
bauwerk durch die eigenen
körperbewegungen frei erkunden kann
ein erlebnis das in der realität nicht
mehr möglich ist
rotterdam ist für besucher gesperrt
es ist eine touristische
sehenswürdigkeit die jedes jahr
millionen menschen jeglichen glaubens
anzieht und ein wichtiges denkmal in der
französischen geschichte und zwar es
wichtig dieser bedeutung im film gerecht
zu werden
pascal niveau aus dem französischen
kultusministerium hat als einer der
wenigen zugang zur baustelle seine
aufgabe das wissen über die kathedrale
zu bewahren
[Musik]
kein gebäude verkörpert so sehr die
geschichte von paris wie notre dame
sie wurde im herzen der stadt gebaut
direkt an der see und alle wichtigen
ereignisse in der geschichte frankreichs
hatten ihre auswirkungen auf noten
parallel zum wiederaufbau arbeiten jetzt
wissenschaftler auf der so genannten
forschungs baustelle notre dame
sie untersuchen zum beispiel freigelegte
baustoffe und können so ganz neue
erkenntnisse gewinnen
[Musik]
die forschung wird nicht nur zum
wiederaufbau beitragen sondern auch
prinzipiell zum verständnis unseres
kulturerbes das filmteam von rebuilding
rotterdam bekam die seltene genehmigung
in der zerstörten kathedrale zu drehen
an manche orte dürfte jedoch nur ein
teammitglied der kamera roboter loses
gemäuer und eine hohe bleibelastung
machen den zugang für menschen zu
gefährlich
wir haben diesen roboter eingesetzt um
in die mitte der kathedrale zu gelangen
unter dieses riesige loch ohne den
roboter wäre das nicht möglich gewesen
die kamera hatte wirklich glück selbst
ich die ja in der ruine war konnte mich
nicht unter das loch stellen aber in der
virtuellen realität schule kann ich dort
hin gehen den film können sich zuschauer
nun weltweit vom zuhause ansehen
und bald soll er auch in einem kino in
paris gezeigt werden
regisseurin chloe ist dankbar mit der
richtigen technik zur richtigen zeit am
richtigen ort gewesen zu sein
[Musik]
als das feuer ausbrach hat uns das daran
erinnert dass nichts unsterblich ist und
dass selbst so ein altes und so tief in
paris verwurzeltes gebäude verschwinden
kann
aber die seele von notre dame ist immer
noch da deshalb bin ich optimistisch
dass es gelingen wird sie zu
restaurieren und ihre frühere schönheit
wieder herzustellen
bis dahin werden wohl noch jahre
vergehen
wer nicht solange warten will kann jetzt
immerhin zum virtuellen touristen werden